G
OUR COUNTRY.
HERE NOW STEPHEN MILLER, AMERICA
FIT LEGAL FOUNDER AND FORR
SENIOR ADVISER TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
STEVEN, IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TOEE
YOU.
THIS IS REALLY A VERY S STORY.
AND  CAN'T HELP BUT THINK THAT
BUT FOR THE REFUSAL OF JOE BIDEN
TO CREATE SE KIND OF REGATOR
AT THE BORDER THA THIS ISIS
FAULT.
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY H FAULT
BECAE JOE BIDEN HAS SENT THE
MESSAGE TO THE WORLD THAT IF YOU
COME TO THE UNITED STATES
ILLEGALLY YOU WILL GET IN.
THE RESULT OF THAT DECISION
TRAGICALLY, HEART BREAKINGLY ARE
INCIDENTS LIKE THIS BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE COMING IN RECORD
NUERS AND RISKING THEIR LIV
IN MANY CASES, MAKING THE
TREACHEROUS JOURNEYND IT'S THE
HEROES O OUR COUNTRY WHO HAVE
TO RISK THEIR LIVES TO SAV
THEM.
THIS WLD ALL STOP TOMROW IF
HE JUST RETURNED TO THE TRUMP
POLICY OF DETAIN AND DEPORT.
BREAK OUR LAWS, THE LAW'S
ENFOED AND DID YOU GO HOME.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE AMAZING
PART OFT, STEVEN, HE HAS THE
HOUSE, THE SENATE, AND THE OVAL.
Y DOESN'T HE DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE BROKEN IMMIGRATION
STEM?
I GOT TO TELL YOU, I'M TIRED OF
HEARING TM SAY IT'S BROKEN
IMMIGRATION.
IT'S NOT BROKEN.
THEY ARE NOT FOLLONG THE LAW
D ALL OF THE SUDDEN THE LAW IS
BROKEN?
THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN?
THIS IS JUST -- THIS IS LUNACY.
IT WILL ONLY GET WORSES --
THIS IS A RUSH ON THE BORDER.
>> THEIR BORDER POLICY IS
EXACTLY THE SAME AS WHAT SOROS
PROSECUTORS ARE DOING IN OUR
CITIES WHICH THEY ARE
UNILATERALLY SUSPENDING
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW AND
GIVING CRIMINALS FREE RAIN.
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT IS LAW
ENFORCEMEN
AND BY SAYING THAT YOU WILL NOT
BE DEPORTED, WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING IS THE LAWS OF THE UNITED
ATES WILL NOT BE ENFORCED.
DONALD TRUMP FIXED THE SYSTEM BY
RESTORG CONSEQUENCES FOR LAW
BREAKS.
E BIDEN SMASHED THE SYSTEM
TO DUST BY ALLOWING EVERYONE
TO BREAK THE LAW WITH IMPUNITY.
>> Judge Jeanine: WELL, TH
IMPUNITY, I MEAN, IALL IT
PRIVILEGE.I CALL IT CRIMINA PRI.
YOU KNOW.
I CALL IT IMMIGRANT PRIVILEGE
RIGHT NOW.
THE PEOPLE COMING HERE ILLEGALLY
HAVE TO HIRE A LAWYER.
THEY HAVE TO, YOU KNOW, SPEAK
THE LANGUAGE.
THEY HAVE TO GIVE THEIR, Y
KNOW, THEIR HONESTY TO THE
UNITED STATES I'M MISSING THE
WORD.
PLEDGE LOYALTY.
>> Judge Jeanine: NONE OF THIS
IS HAPPENING A BEING FLOWN
INTO THE INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY
FASTER THAN THEY'RE COM IN.
NOW THEY ARE SING WELL, IT'S
NOT FAIR YOU SHOULDN'T BE
SENDG THEM TO THE INTERIOR.
WHAT SHOULD WOULD HE BE DOINGWI?
>> THE ONLY SOLUTION, THE ONLY
LUTION IS TO END CATCH AND
RELEASE.
WHICH IS THE O THING THAT JOE
BIDEN WILL NEVER DO SINCE HIS
GOAL IS MAXIMUM ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
EVERYHOICE HE HAS MADE FROM
TERMINATINGPP.
TERMINATG SAFE THIRD
AGREEMENTS AND TERNATING EVERY
THAT DONALDRUMP PUT IN PLACE
IS TO PUT THEM IN THE COUNT.
THAT'S WHY M ORGANIZATION
AMERICA FIRST ABSOLUTELY SUING
THEENERAL PAXTON TO SP THE
RESCISSION OF TITLE 42.
>> Judge Jeanine: I ONLY HAVE A
FEW SECONDS LEFT.
WHAT IS E BIDEN'S END GL
HERE?
JUST TO LET EVERYBODY IN TO
AMERICA UNTIL, WHEN?
>>
>> YOU ARE WITNESSING IT UNTIL
ALL OF THE COUNTRY RESEMBLES THE
SAME POLITICAL EXPERIMENT THAT
TOOKLACE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS ULTIMATELY THEIR BELIEF,
THEIR DESIGNND THEIR
JECTIVE.
THEY THINK THAT HAVING MASSIVE
UNCONTROLLED ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
WILL MAKE THIS COUNT A MORE
LIBERAL, MORE LEFT WING LESS
CONSERVATIVE CNTRY.
THAT'S THEIR BELIEF.
THAT'S THEIR PLAN.
AND THEY ARE PLAYING IT THRGH.
AND ALL THE PEOPLE DYING ARE
JU COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW SAD
HOW SAD.
THANK YOU, STEPHEN MILLE